I don't know why we don't feel like  we're doing great right you work hard  you do all the stuff you're supposed to  be doing you're doing your best and  still you feel like it's not enough I  think it's social media I think since  social media came out before social  media I thought I was kicking ass  I really did now every time I open my  phone someone's in my face are you  killing it today are you living a  hundred percent maxed out energy are you  living your best life  no I'm not  not doing any of those things because  that's not normal  I don't care what the Rock's Instagram  says that's not normal  you know what's normal how you feel  right now right now in your funny little  gassy bodies  a little achy a little tired lightheaded  taking deep breaths so you don't pass  out in front of your friends  worried about your bills worried about  how you're getting home worried about  that thing you found on your ass  that's normal